this week on brian ross investigates a
house of horrors the new york city
rikers island prison a lawless place
where guards run so-called fight nights
he will give us conversation like
cigarettes or
drugs or food
and stuff like that to like do stuff to
other inmates last incident that i had
i'm not
horribly overcrowded and now a new
expose about the more than 15 deaths in
the last year inside the walls of this
despicable place
rikers island has been a national
embarrassment
it is a stain on our city
plus the legal troubles for donald trump
continued to mount a criminal grand jury
now investigating in georgia and demands
for his children to tell what they know
david k johnson is here with the latest
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of meteorite
but these vaccines these mrna vaccines
the mrna cova vaccines need to be
withdrawn from the market now no one
should get them no one should get
boosted
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and ronda we begin tonight with a
disturbing story about a true house of
whores the giant new york city jail
rikers island a filthy lawless
overcrowded place that the new mayor of
new york has rightly called a national
embarrassment and a stain on the city
rhonda
that's right brian and most of the 5 000
plus people held there are only a
waiting trial they haven't been
convicted of anything but their lives
are in danger virtually every hour of
every day brian
set on a 400 acre island near laguardia
airport in new york city rikers island
is one of the world's largest and no
doubt worst city jails
and even the repeated expose of what
happens inside the walls here like this
video of the so-called fight night
organized by the gangs overlooked by the
guards have not led to any serious
reforms
the fight night video was obtained by
the new york times at new york channel
pix11 talked to one of the inmates who
says he was forced to participate
they will give us compensation like
cigarettes or
drugs or food
and stuff like that to like do stuff to
other inmates last incident that i had
i'm not going out and i peed on them the
ceo paid me to do it
it is a lawless place where prison gangs
not prison guards seem to be in charge
investigative reporters at the new york
post obtained photos from inside showing
as many as 26 men stuffed into single
cells
the new yorker magazine documented how
one young man got lost in the system
held in solitary confinement for almost
three years without a trial for
allegedly stealing a backpack he later
committed suicide
island has been a national embarrassment
and we have ignored it
and for far too long and the situation
there has been unacceptable
it is a stain on our city
and now new york magazine has done its
own deep dive documenting how some 15
inmates died at or shortly after leaving
rikers island last year alone
and we're joined now by the two
journalists from new york magazine who
did that incredible article of bliss
broyard and lisa reardon seville thank
you both for being here let me start by
asking you who were these men who died
and how did they die well um the men
ranged from age 24 to 64.
um 11 out of the 16 that died in new
york city custody this year all but one
at rikers had mental illness issues or
addiction issues and they died in a
variety of ways in many cases a factor
was the
there was an adequate staff to attend to
a medical emergency
or to provide a suicide watch in the
case where people were
at risk from self-harm so these are
people that really are in need of
services more than they're in need of
sitting in jail
and lisa these are men who for the most
part uh were awaiting trial or just
there for sort of technical parole
violations
yeah and that's true at rikers across
the board some 95 of the people
incarcerated on rikers island are
pre-trial so they have not yet been
convicted of the crime that they were
arrested for
but for many particularly during cobit
that extended for weeks months and even
years
incredibly overcrowded horrible
conditions that you documented through
these 15 cases
take me through some of them bliss
javier velasco um
had been in and out of rikers about
seven different times in the last 10
years and he was a
son of immigrants
a man the reporters found who struggled
with alcohol addiction accused of
domestic abuse so the last time that he
went in he said that he was going to
kill himself and he told the arresting
officer
he told his wife amanda she told the
parole officer she told the assistant
d.a the da's boss
and they all said that he was
manipulating her you know that not to
take it seriously so he did have a
suicide attempt
um in rutgers that he was cut down from
he was rescued kind of just in time he
was moved into suicide watch
and for some reason perhaps because of
staffing shortages it only went on for
24 hours and then when the suicide watch
was removed he was successful
lisa you found the same thing with the
cases you've been looking at closely
yeah there are resonances between um
javier velasco's story and that of isa
abdul karim
locked up for what is called a technical
parole violation failing to report to
his parole officer he had compromised
health and when he was at rikers this
was a time when
intake was very crowded
sleeping really one on top of another
and he contracted cobin
and he was
in the infirmary on and off at the time
the new york governor had signed a law
ordering the release of those held on
such technical parole violations after
30 days and he had been there just short
of 30 days
so he was not eligible for release
and
on his 32nd or 33rd day
is died of a pulmonary embolism linked
to his coved
so this is a story in which this is a
man with serious health issues
and was not there on a serious charge
and he died there
your excellent reporting is not the
first time that journalists have taken a
hard look at rikers island yet the place
is still open for business crowded a
house of horrors why isn't anything done
about it well um
you know it has a very powerful union
for their correction officers
who are
invested in having a large staff
so the union for example has not been
supportive of
mayor de blasio and now mayor adams
commitment to close rikers and move to
smaller borough-based jails because part
of that plan also requires incarceration
but lisa is it also fair to say that
there is a kind of public apathy about
what goes on in jails and prisons
there's not a push to reform from the
public
we tend to feel that if someone ends up
in a jail or prison they should be there
and we're not always concerned about why
whether or not they did that crime um
or
or what happens to them there
and
when the fears of rising crime come up
we tend to revert very quickly back to
lock them up throw away the key so um
i think that there's a
there's a question as we are dealing
with the ravages of a pandemic with a
very complex social moment to look back
and ask
um
who are we mad at who do we want to
punish
who are we afraid of and also
what kind of
society do we want to have and if we ask
those questions we have to look at our
jails and prisons
well lisa riordan seville and bliss
broyard thank you so much and terrific
reporting and they brought a real sharp
spotlight on a very serious
long-standing issue thank you both for
being with us here tonight thank you
thanks for having us
up next the legal troubles of the former
president he calls it a political witch
hunt we'll get a reality check from a
pulitzer prize-winning investigative
reporter you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
it's been just over a year now since
president donald trump became the
ex-president and a private citizen
ending any official immunity he may have
enjoyed while in office and now
prosecutors investigators are circling
he calls it a political witch hunt and
because the investigations in new york
washington georgia and elsewhere are
ongoing it can be hard to evaluate what
jeopardy he may really be facing so to
get a reality check we're joined tonight
by david k johnston a good friend the
pulitzer prize-winning investigative
reporter who has chronicled the business
affairs of donald trump for decades in a
series of books the latest called of the
big cheat david welcome to the program
tonight how much jeopardy does donald
trump now face
oh he's in serious real trouble at long
long last after
uh spending essentially more than half a
century swindling people refusing to pay
workers
cheating investors cheating governments
the the biggest concern he has to have
is with the manhattan grand jury because
those are criminal charges and i
anticipate that there will be a new york
state racketeering charge brought
against him eventually
the most immediate news issue has been
about the new york state attorney
general who's an elected official who
has inherent civil but not criminal
authority she can have criminal
authority in some cases but this is a
civil proceeding she filed a 115 page
brief
documenting frauds by donald trump
and said essentially we are now moving
on to other frauds
and this was in support of her subpoenas
to require donald trump don jr and
ivanka to come in and testify as second
son eric did when he repeatedly took the
fifth amendment against
self-incrimination
and david in georgia the prosecutor
there has now been given permission to
empower a grand jury but not until may
what's the case down there
well the fulton county district attorney
whose district is essentially the city
of atlanta
is pursuing trump's efforts under in
violation of both state and federal law
to rig the outcome of the election brad
ratzenberger a republican who was the
chief elected elections official in
georgia has said he would testify but
only if he was subject to a subpoena he
wasn't going to come in voluntarily the
delay is a little troubling because
republicans in the legislature have
talked about
enacting a new law to prevent this
investigation from going forward
and david a question for you from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
donald trump has been complaining
bitterly that the attorney general has
been targeting his children the children
are 40 years old ivanka trump worked as
a white house advisor
why is she naming them what is the role
what is their role in this affair now
isn't it amazing that donald refers to
his middle-aged kids
as a children i certainly wouldn't do
that with my middle-aged kid
um don jr was is the sole trustee of
some of the trump businesses and he's
been actively involved in managing
uh the trump business at a time when
they made just outrageous claims for
example there's a piece of property
brian and i have talked about in the
past a westchester golf course that in
one forum trump has said is worth 1.3 or
1.4 million dollars
but in documents to banks more than 100
million and this presidential disclosure
forms he
checked the top box
more than 50 million
you know you could argue 1.3 million to
2 million and that's a range but if
you're claiming 15 100 million
in other forums then the 1.3 million it
clearly suggests uh fraudulent behavior
ivanka was apparently the point person
in negotiating with the banks
and in new york state we have very
strong business records laws lying to a
bank falsifying business records is a
serious crime in new york state and
that's why she would be on the witness
list and by the way when they come in i
would expect
donald trump don jr and ivanka to rely
heavily on their fifth amendment right
against self-incrimination
david as you know prosecutors often use
potential charges against children as
leverage against the bigger target is
that going to be the case here do you
think
oh they're very definitely trying to
split up the family on these issues
which is a standard tactic
uh the interesting thing will be uh what
goes on with donald even with his family
loyalty to donald is a one-way street
and intensely close as he is to ivana
ivanka
uh
i think push comes to shove he'll break
with her
uh and he certainly won't have any
difficulty breaking with his sons where
you know we have recorded examples of
where he has referred to them as being
idiots and incompetence and other
negative terms
what do you think now is the timetable
for potential charges in the new york
case in manhattan
well the prosecutors in new york were
expecting a million pages of documents
they got five million pages they have to
go through and not just look at but
really analyze all of those records less
something unexpected appear out of
nowhere
in the trial so this is going to take
some more time
the grand jury that originally sat asked
to be released
and a new grand jury has been impaneled
but i would
expect that we're going to see something
sometime this year uh the phrase i've
used in the past and people said it's
about to happen
uh is simply we're getting closer every
day we're getting closer
we keep hearing that he calls a
political witch hunt but doesn't sound
like a witch hunt it sounds like they've
got a very solid basis here to continue
to investigate
well if it is a witch hunt they've got
themselves a witch
uh you know donald's record of lying
cheating stealing
is something i've been chronicling
from the public record since 1988
and what's really astonishing is how
he's gotten away with all of this and it
goes to a fundamental law and crime
problem in america
we have very tough rules on people who
commit street crimes as in
rikers island where just technical
violations your parole can end up
becoming death sentences
on the other hand white collar crimes
are abundantly
filled with excuses and exit gates and
and ways to explain away your behavior
and we don't spend nearly as much law
enforcement efforts to go after this
even though white collar crime does
vastly more economic damage
than street crime absolutely david k
johnson thank you so much for being here
tonight david's latest book is the big
cheat
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media you'll want to see the
choices made by the editors of meteorite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the editor chief
of mediaite which like the law and crime
trial network is part of the dan abrams
media group and aiden for this week's
winner you've chosen nbc news justice
correspondent pete williams who broke a
very big story this week
that's right so uh pete williams was the
first to report the biggest news of the
day probably the biggest news of the
week uh which is that supreme court
justice stephen breyer will be retiring
at the end of his current term uh the
big consequence of that of course is
that president joe biden will be able to
nominate the first justice of his
presidency
but it was a huge scoop for williams
who's one of the best reporters uh on
the justice department and supreme court
beats uh he was the first to break the
story at around 11 45 a.m this morning
and the other networks didn't confirm
his own reporting until afternoon uh so
it was pretty world-class stuff from uh
from pete williams but i think what
we've come to expect ryan from uh from a
reporter of his caliber absolutely he's
the best he has at least a four minute
lead on the others which in the world of
network news is a lifetime
right exactly and uh and yeah i mean i
he he's broken a scoop after scoop for
nbc news um so you know it's no surprise
that he's one of their senior
correspondents um and this this
reporting apparently surprised uh the
justice breyer um who expected to be
able to announce the news himself a
little bit closer to june uh when
justices typically announced their
retirements um so you know some some
other reporters said that briar was uh
was a little bit upset that uh he got
scooped by uh pete williams but that's
not a pete williams's concern uh he got
the big story uh months before it was
set to be announced right he continues
to be the gold standard for network news
coverage of the courts and of the
justice department for loser you've
chosen alex berenson a once highly
regarded new york times reporter and
successful spy thriller novelist but
these vaccines these mrna vaccines the
mrna cova vaccines need to be withdrawn
from the market now no one should get
them no one should get boosted no one
should get double boosted
they are a dangerous and ineffective
product at this point against omicron
so
you know when we saw this on uh tucker
carlson last night alex berenson uh has
emerged during the pandemic um as a uh
what we call a coveted truther um he's
weaved a number of conspiracy theories
about the pandemic mostly on tucker
carlson's show and when we saw this his
latest commentary last night one of our
editors rolled his eyes and thought that
we wouldn't cover it um we ended up
doing so because i think it's genuinely
his most wrong and also probably his
most dangerous comment yet on fox news
he made two main claims about uh the
vaccines he said that they were
dangerous and ineffective and so that
they should be recalled
now obviously that's just wrong on its
face um he's basing his claim that the
vaccines are ineffective on the
incorrect belief that they are not
stopping infection of the omicron
variant but new cdc studies and every
study for that matter shows that not
only do the vaccines prevent
hospitalization and death protect
against hospitalization and death they
also protect against infection um even
from the omicron variant they're a
little bit less effective uh versus
previous variants but they're still
better than being unvaccinated the fact
that alex berenson continues to be
booked on the most watched network on
cable news is a travesty for both fox
news and for tucker carlson remains the
only host on fox news who continues to
book alex parents it's a sense that
there's no shame there about putting
somebody on the air who is again and
again proven to be wrong again again
proven to be wrong and just factually
incorrect on its face
and it's not just that there's also a
lack of accountability um because
executives at fox news i know through my
own reporting know that this is wrong
and know that it's a problem that
they're putting on false information
about uh life-saving vaccines on the air
but they just don't do anything about it
because tucker carlson is more powerful
than the executives at this network and
as long as he continues to get good
ratings i take it he'll continue to have
that power
right he gets continues to get more than
three million viewers a night which is
triple what anyone's getting on cnn and
while that is still the case and while
he still has a very powerful audience
that will be enraged if there's any sort
of accountability uh he'll continue to
run the network
all right blade mclaughlin thank you so
much for being here and thanks to all of
you also for being here tonight we'll be
back again next week and hope you'll
join us then
for brian ross investigates the law and
crime trial network have a good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you